mean mass Supreme Court has rejected the
final appeal of two Reuters journalists
serving a prison sentence because if
they're reporting on the country's
crackdown on drawing up Muslims chaucer
oh and Walloon have spent more than 16
months in detention they were arrested
during an investigation if their killing
of 10 Rohingya Muslim men during a
military crackdown in the western part
of Myanmar a district court sentenced
the two journalists to seven years in
prison last September for illegally
possessing official documents they've
been since awarded the Pulitzer Prize
for their work for ma foreman RDW
Southeast Asia correspondent Charlotte
shells and bill joins me Charlotte now
that this appeal has been rejected what
prospect the journalists have of being
released I'm Rita well there is now no
higher court that these journalists can
take their appeal to the Supreme Court
is Myanmar's top court so that really
does quash any hopes for these
journalists of some sort of judicial
reprieve that doesn't mean to say though
that all hopes are lost their supporters
have been putting out statements today
saying that they will continue to do all
they can to secure the release of these
journalists a lawyer for the two men has
also said that perhaps petitioning the
president is an option of Miramar is an
option that they will consider at the
moment though there is no sign of any
sort of presidential pardon so this
ruling today really is a huge blow to
the journalists themselves their wives
who were in court to hear that ruling
come down and also their supporters many
of whom around the world are deeply
concerned by this case and fear that
it's a it's a signal over a decline in
freedom of expression in Myanmar unsure
what message does this verdict sent to
other journalist investigating
allegations of human rights violations
in Myanmar one human rights organization
in the lead-up to this ruling had
documented what
called a climate of fear among
journalists in Myanmar now this ruling
today is is likely to only increase that
climate of fear in fact Amnesty
International has said that this is a
real blow to press freedom in Myanmar
also pointed out though that it's not
just journalists who who it is concerned
forward it also says that there has been
a crackdown on freedom of expression
among other critics of authorities in
Myanmar it's pointed out that it's
alleged that in the last few days a
number of other critics have been
arrested in Myanmar so there is some
real concern a lot of people as well
very angry actually rights groups at
sang sung shoot sushi that a facto
leader of Myanmar they'd hoped that she
would come out in defense of these
journalists and in fact she gave a
statement in the build-up to this ruling
saying that so she didn't believe that
these journalists were arrested for
journalism she said that in essence they
violated the law in Myanmar now that
reporting by these two reporters
journalists and their colleagues has
been awarded a Pulitzer Prize the house
had gone done with authorities in
Myanmar that's right their colleagues
from Reuters completed the investigation
following their arrest and published its
findings now since those findings were
released Myanmar has arrested and jailed
a number of soldiers in connection with
that with the Reuters publication which
alleged that the military had been
involved in the massacre of reinjure
Muslim men and boys and now the
authorities in Myanmar in general deny
any such atrocities they say that their
crackdown on the row hinge of Muslims
has been targeting insurgents and
militants and it denies any attacks on
civilians
Charlotte rosin pill in Bangkok thank
you very much for that update